[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur rallye fällt
heute gibt es ein rezept anlässlich des
valentinstags haben sich einfach meine
zuschauer gewünscht also nicht dass du
jetzt laufe ich feiere den valentinstag
mit dir ja ich habe einmal von dir was
bekommen einmal komm hol mal kurz den
baum weg unseren lebensbaum liebsten das
ist und zwar haben wir zwei uns
kennengelernt
im jahr man war es 2008 und 2007 was so
2007 und im februar waren wir noch nicht
verheiratet und dann hat er mir am
valentinstag beim globus kurz vor
ladenschluss noch ein baum gekauft sowie
egger sagt schwarz aber was ich mache
mache ich zeige ja und außerdem wo der
browser sei dafür ist einfach zu viel
mehr feiertagen um mit den geburtstagen
kommando egal wie der aussieht egal man
soll schon sehen dass der so aussieht
genau
ja da sind müssen begründet
und zwar hier ist unsere hilfe ist und
immer wenn man vergessen den zoo in
gießen dann werden halt die gelbe
blätter gelb morath jetzt müssen wir
aber wieder dran frechen und ich habe
angst ich kenne ich halt bonsai bäume
nicht aus und ich habe angst dass wenn
ich ihnen halt mal abschneide dass er
dann komplett stirbt und da bin ich
glaube ja ja ja nur sagen weil dienstag
bei kloster vor zwei monaten war
weihnachten ja es gibt noch geburtstag
es kommt halloween ja so viele anlässe
von lechia danzig kommt gar nicht weg
ich kann gar nicht mehr raus ich auch
und deswegen denken ja auch viele dass
der valentinstag ja aus kommerz zwecken
erfunden wo er das auch so habe ich
erzähle mal ganz kurz die geschichte zum
valentin fragen bitte hör auf das ist
reiner kommerz nein ich erzählen
viele glauben ja dass der valentinstag
eine erfindung der blumengeschäfte sei
oder als kommerz idee aus den usa
importiert wurde
mag sein dass etwas wahres dran ist aber
eigentlich liegen die wurzeln in italien
hier wirkte der bischof valentin dass
sich für die liebenden im christlichen
sinn einsetzte und zwar vermählte er
heimlich paare was in der damaligen zeit
eben verboten war murat dafür bezahlte
er schließlich mit seinem leben und
wurde eben am 14 februar hingerichtet
und gilt seither als märtyrer
die basilika san valentino hat sich
seitdem zum wallfahrtsort der lebenden
aus der ganzen welt entwickler situation
also auch sie haben wir zwar noch nie da
und viele reisen jetzt hin und dort vor
der kirche erneut das liebes versprechen
und trotz der ernsthaftigkeit und des
traurigen hintergrund ist verstehen die
menschen diesen tag als fest der liebe
und feiern in romantisch also alle
feinen romantisch nur wir zwar nicht
wahrscheinlich aber ist egal ich habe
trotzdem gedacht kommt humor den
zuschauern was gutes deswegen gibt's
hier kleine cupcakes mit einer
liebesbotschaft und zwar sind die also
wer ist für kommerz und wer ist für tag
der liebenden ich glaube ich bin für
kommerz moore ist kommerz haben dann
nicht für tag erleben und die cellistin
weswegen man gespannt was die zuschauer
den sagen ja bin ich auch und hier haben
wir einen cupcake der hat hier oben
drauf einen kleinen liebesbrief dasteht
aber nix drin
aber wenn man den kaffee dann auf ist
dann kommt eine kleine überraschung ich
sage jetzt zuerst einmal die zutaten für
den muffin teig und dann geht es nämlich
was los ist und commerce kein kommerz
also komme cupcakes wirklich für die
muffins brauch ich 150 gramm zucker
einen halben teelöffel backpulver nden
viertel teelöffel natron eine prise salz
und eine tonkabohne hier habe ich noch
160 gramm mehl 40 gramm kakaopulver
etwas vanille extrakt zweier einen
espresso und jeweils 150 milliliter
buttermilch und sonnenblumenöl für die
marines werden jetzt die trockenen
zutaten einfach kurz vermischt und da
kommen noch die flüssigen zutaten mit
rein und werden ganz kurz ein gerührt
für den geschmack gebe ich jetzt noch
espresso oder zudem könnt ihr auch gerne
weglassen und für den richtig leckeren
geschmack kommt noch ein bisschen traum
carbon mit rein das ist ein tolles
gewürzt
was so ein bisschen nach waldmeister und
auch vanille schmeckt und richtig lecker
ist
den teig fühle jetzt mit einem eis
portionierer in zwölf muffin förmchen
die muffins werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 25 minuten gebacken die
backzeit nutze ich jetzt und kann jetzt
schon mal die deko vorbereiten
und hier habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
blüten passt eher weich geknetet und da
jetzt mit rosa lebensmittel verpasste
leicht eingefärbt
und die blüten passt da wird jetzt auf
becker strecke dünn ausgerollt
damit ich daraus jetzt die
briefumschläge formen kann muss ich
jetzt natürlich rechtecke zu schneiden
das mache ich jetzt mit dem cygnet aber
ihr könnt auch ein messer oder eine
pizza hut einfach nehmen
und damit den briefumschlag jetzt
richtig formen kann schneide ich oben
und unten eine spitze zu das heißt
einmal mache ich mir das ganze als
schablone und kann dann so die
restlichen aufzuschneiden
und jetzt kann ich oben und unten die
spitze einklappen und mit essbares leber
ankleben
und die briefumschläge könnt ihr dann
mit kleinen sachen herzen versiegeln und
das ist auch ideal für alle die zum
beispiel keinen herz ausstecher haben
dafür nehmen die die modelle schokolade
formt eine kleine kugel daraus jetzt
nehmen die jetzt zwischen die finger und
drückt sie leicht blatt und zwischen
zeigefinger und daumen könnt ihr dann
diese spitze formen und dann ein
scharfes messer verwenden und oben
mittig reindrücken
und so entsteht die herzform
die muffins abgekühlt und jetzt kommt
die überraschung mit rein
ich habe jetzt hier einen ausstecher da
ist und ihr könnt das ganze aber auch
ohne ausstecher machen und einfach ein
messer benutzen
so sieht ein bisschen sauberer aus aber
später sieht man die öffnung sowieso
nicht hier kann ich denn jetzt ein
stechen und du meistens kommt der teil
schon mit raus mir nicht
nehmt ihr ein messer und vater ein und
hebt den teil aber auf also nicht
aufessen und dann so ein bisschen was
rausholen
das sind der mitte eben auch ein schönes
loch entsteht und wir dann hier dieser
ganzen zucker streusel verstecken können
ich habe jetzt hier diesen kussmund in
rosa und rot und habe noch so süße
kleine herzchen mit dabei und die sind
richtig goldig auch ganz hübsch finde
ich habe hier einfach mit kleine
liebesbotschaft gemacht da könnte er
drauf schreiben was ihr möchtet und dann
könnt ihr das hier zusammenrollen und
auch mit drin verstecken aber jetzt
erstmal alle aushöhlen die teile dürften
nicht wegschmeißen den deckel habe ich
jetzt hier weggeschnitten das innere
könnt ihr gerne gleich vernaschen aber
den deckel brauchen genau jetzt neben
dir am besten entweder einen kleinen
löffel oder erfüllt die förmchen mit den
fingern und dann kommt das ganze hier
rein natürlich mit der liebesbotschaft
und da kommt dann gleich der muffins
deckel wieder drauf und da ist jetzt
ganz wichtig dass die botschaft nicht so
klein ist denn ich habe dir gestern
schon mal zur probe gebacken und zwar zu
zwei zettel wurden mit gegessen was soll
ich sagen was gegessen hat der moral
darren mitgegessen liebe geht durch den
magen oder müsste vom hersteller im
versteck liebe geht durch den magen
jetzt sind alle muffins so und jetzt
habe ich eine creme bereits vorbereitet
dann nehmt ihr eure lieblings creme
ich habe jetzt hier die creme von meinem
grundrezept video also die lockere sahne
creme und wie werde ich jetzt hier
darauf stützen
jetzt kommen hier einfach nur noch die
süßen herzchen darauf die ich gemacht
habe und natürlich die liebesbriefe
[Musik]
so sehen die cupcakes aus wichtig ist
dass ihr die lego erst daten drauf gibt
wenn auch wirklich gegessen wird genau
das problem
schön anscheinend mit drucker mohne er
beißt rein aber bitte es entweder den
zettel ruhig es ist nur die ich es
lieber mit mit kabel oder sehr cool aus
buch mein gott
guck mal hat für apple mich nein
wirklich ist so schön so viel kommerz
belieben gemacht du veräppelt schmeckt
und ist folglich das kitschig nein ich
nicht all das stehe überraschung
überraschungs fach gefunden natürlich
ist dort die nachricht drin natürlich
nicht für dich bestimmt
egal warte so dass ich jetzt gemacht
werden als reingebissen
gestern hat es mit gegessen ich hab's
dir nicht sagen wollen jetzt ehrlich ist
hat gestern keine nachrichten gab es
auch gewesen darunter dazu klein also
wirklich wichtig zeit der groß genug
machen da jetzt nochmals der kaffee
schmeckt es zu boden und wir haben ein
konto ohne drin ja und das kann es dann
nicht wenn die streuseln wie brause ja
da spreche ich mich auch nicht also die
kann man echt gut mir da sind die
steuern also hier steht hab dich lieb
auf einer fußball lehrer
jetzt hat das cupcake können wir jetzt
noch nicht möglich
also falls ihr das rezept gerne
nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei auf see lief - blog.de da
steht alles noch mal ganz genau
murat kann sich jetzt nach drehschluss
noch ein bisschen über den valentinstag
aufregen und ihr dürft gerne weiterhin
stellen ich bin bereit ich bin der
grinch des valentinstag wahrscheinlich
mit video und einfach zu kommentieren
kommerz oder liebe wir gucken mal bis
zur nächsten x 10 schuss aber schmeckt
lecker ist mit richtig frisch ja
nicht so schwer
[Musik]